it's the voice in the head that creates
a large part of your
unhappiness and that's quite a
realization
and that applies to small situations it
applies to bigger situations too and
some people live with
a a very a critical
and very negative voice in their head
for
years they live with something they
criticize
themselves continuously some of them or
they criticize
continuously other people and situations
there's always something wrong
with wrong with me over the situation or
they tell themselves stories of how
how bad bad my life is how
unfairly i've been treated by life and
other people
and it's i have i wasn't given a chance
and now it's all over it there's no
point in even trying too old now to
it could very people carry very unhappy
stories around in their head
and they call that my life they're not
that many people who are really
happy with their lives they're more
people around who are
unhappy with their lives my life didn't
go the way it was meant to go it didn't
go the way
i was expecting it to go things
many things went wrong and so people
carry unhappy stories and they did they
derive their sense of identity
from the unhappy story not real i think
that's it's an american story they call
it
me and my life so that is a
and nobody nobody has pointed out to
them
this is not it does not have to be that
way
you can you can become aware of
the stories that you're telling yourself
the stories that give you your sense of
your unhappy
sense of self
the and realize that is these are
certain thoughts i call it thoughts that
create what we call
your life situation your life situation
your past and your so-called future
and there's no life situation that is
not problematic everybody has their set
of problems
every life situation has its
difficulties and its problems if it's
not one thing it's another
you cannot go through life without
experiencing almost continuously
i do i problems of my the word
i prefer is challenges you cannot go
through life without continuously
experiencing challenges either of
interpersonal relationship challenges
close relationship challenges health
challenges
physical challenges financial challenges
professional work challenges
living situation child is there's always
something that goes wrong somewhere
so that's only to be expected but this
does not have to have to become
evolved into an unhappy story of me and
my life
so you you you're able to differentiate
between
the story of my life my so-called life
the my life situation
in my and life
so in the power of now i write about
the importance of distinguishing between
what you what is your life situation
which includes
all your problems and your past and all
those things that's fine that exists
but in addition to your life situation
which exists in time past and future
there's something more vital and
i call that your life now
your life situation as i said exists in
time
but your life is now
so if your attention moves into the
present moment
it's a little bit like waking up out of
this
dream of continuous thinking useless
thinking
not not constructive thinking useless
thinking
that tells you how unhappy you are so
that kind of thinking
that creates an unhappy fictitious
mental entity that you think is you
useless thinking you step out of that
which is almost like a dream of
a hypnotic trance of useless thinking
you step out of that and suddenly it's a
bit
like somebody who's waking up from a
dream
and this is why usb used spiritually we
often use the term
awakening it's used in many traditions
spiritual awakening
you wake up out of this
stream of thinking into the present
moment
so you suddenly become alert
and a moment ago you were still thinking
about
how awful your life is that's your life
situation
maybe it is awful but that's an
interpretation
there's your life situation what about
your life
what do you mean by life well this
moment is your life
it always your life is always this
moment
is there anything wrong with this moment
a question i asked in the power of now
what is your problem right now if you're
really present because when you come
into the present moment
which is all there ever is and in this
present moment
what is your problem
and then you have to wake i really wake
up into the present moments and see well
right now i'm breathing
i'm sitting here and i'm looking around
and i'm seeing
a bit of sky and i'm seeing a potted
plant and they're seeing the flowers
it's all quite lovely and it's
relatively quiet here
the temperature is fine and i may even
feel
that i'm there's there's an aliveness in
my body
i breathe and i feel alive there is
every cell is alive i call it the inner
body awareness you become
aware that you're alive in your body
so you're stepping out of your mind
you're stepping into sense perceptions
come to your senses and you also come
into your body and then you're in you're
now in the present moment
that's your life and yes
of course you have to deal with the
stuff in your life situation
but not be lost in it you deal with it
when the moment comes when you are able
to
take action or do something then you
deal with it
but you're no longer lost in it and
you're no longer completely absorbed by
by this unhappy pseudo identity that
that's created by useless thinking so
you come
into the present moment this is your
life
and the rest is your life situation
and then after a while you are able to
balance
your dealing with your life situation
and experiencing life directly and
then then a beginning to appreciate
the present moment and realizing that
it's actually quite wonderful